found out - why [ __ ] shouts a christian
laettner - oh dude
54% snakes hell yeah
yes but speaking of white rappers though
we got some more there's nothing that
makes me happy in the white rappers
really there's not it's so it's just
good for you man
mmm when they tell you can't you can you
know yeah so you know our chance little
brows you guys remember a little brown
hours caterpillar eyes Hillary he went
hard dude
so we got some contenders though oh yeah
we have some new ones got some new
trying to knock off the king of the
mountain
knock off brow bronze example brows
again just want everything to be
refreshed with [ __ ] with that verbal
gerbil hit on brow play the last 20
seconds hidden brows huh King in the
sting Brendan and do fighter and create
a long relationship a CEO more
specifically bolder Brendan came in with
the chip on the shoulder but is going to
get is don't buy your original my king
in this thing your biography be hear you
loud and clear
get me out of here is way too loud in
here watching that Irishman eat pizza
drinking half of here and kid thinking
like the type of dog that has Arita a
song cigarettes with a snapback
on not to hit the crib intense nap chat
on Hank is a good we still mess twitch
at 1800 Pico Boulevard over the head
Thursday a blowout a minute late
I wanted to rap I had a demonstrate
brand new studio yo let's go and get you
to a date my fave Nick send me that
track my walk on stage that [ __ ] from
now on hell yeah tasty bro that puts me
in a good mood we're doing something
right Lyle Lyle if you're right calm or
a road rage what's in that cup is that D
ball dark roast I got some Gold's Gym
brother win straw with cream you got a
back dude didn't you get your blood work
done yeah they say well they says
there's a lot of black in your blood
they said they did find a couple
brothers in the stream they said there's
long low DS although with floaties on
everybody calm down
alarm here your blood works fine there's
a lot of darkness and everybody you know
like on some rays of light that's
supposed to be in there they're like oh
we just want a crying Jordan here blood
like oh that's me yeah that's mine
that's fine uh no what did they say I
have a call with them today 3 p.m. to
find out but there's a company called
uh-oh I mean there's just a company that
travels around and they they'll come
take your blood they did it last week
after we got done I took my blood
they're gonna tell me we this week
what's going on but they did tell me
that I got too much blood in me so I got
to drain some blood how does that happen
they test this thing called hemoglobin
it's the one that looks like a Halloween
sounds like a Halloween costume and they
test that when an if you have it's high
then you have to drain some blood so I'm
giving blood away there you so you're
gonna give some blood and then are they
gonna put you on to the playoffs put you
on some TRT they met people who know
some TRT or some uppers or assad wazers
at least no Downers probably but we'll
see because also I don't know who's get
your blood I don't know some ladies my
honest
and all the time just [ __ ] you
somebody's like where's my tail
I got an accent I have an some reason I
hate this guy Brendan Schaub
ice won't be mean to him all the time
oh I can easily tell you what it is dude
is because you're like a [ __ ]
cannibal that ate his whole family okay
cannibal irks around at Duncan Daniel
let me get on that JaMarcus Russell
Jersey he's from your [ __ ] neck of
the woods from LSU
bro you threw one deep ball some dumbass
like number one pick number one [ __ ]
but first of all then he bought a fur
coat yeah dude but the fur was all
[ __ ] it was in Chile real diet in a
straight scissor remember he was like
six gallons deep on moszer alright hit
this white rapper who is he Daniel dang
mic ramble
[Music]
oh boy leave that baby that hotshot Ram
hot boys hot boys gang gang
I do the damn thing hanging this thing
I'm repping big brown a rat King the Oh
farm put the dawn put the moonlit dawn
every single city he'd be looking for a
single mom yeah that's a trip and I'm a
drip like Derek raw doggin with his
chick to a Knick can't quit hate and get
your feet up for the pic had to make it
really quick but tell me what you think
say what up kid Gianni here mom [ __ ]
twig got paid a biblical forth oh quit
touching me but keep touching me bro yo
yo really nice you're coming in with
that soft white heat that's an easy
listen
yeah baby Jimmy stalker bro yeah
comfortable brother rolling through your
eardrums dawg that's not white art Kelly
[ __ ] yeah dude that's that sex with only
adults are Kelly sure I wasn't mad at
that
no I'm not mad at that at all day my
heart all right guys in this we have
another one what this is the contender
Tyler Dale oh [ __ ] Tyler Dale yeah Benny
God is and I'm talking color flour also
God whips any type of horsepower gotta
give credit when credit dude hey oh man
I'm talking about you grown man really
fill them shoes Channel [ __ ] seven
leaving Clues gang hangs on the news
yeah if he reaches to the heavens
looking photos
tell I'm better and you better tell you
folks used to do shows for $5 pack of
smokes now we making gold buzz buzz all
about the honey 10 whips new shoes any
guy in honey hair slicked back like it's
always sunny gang gang buzz buzz one
love [ __ ] makes me wanna buy a 96
Mustang put the top down about to go to
enterprise run a Mustang Wow bro couple
cheaters bro I love that rat ah that rat
face they got on there too bro yeah is
that a wolf is that a rat that's a rat
baby that's the hardest right you ever
seen that's a wolf baby it's all good
though I know a rat when I see a rat son
yeah I don't know well you boys think so
you guys are picking one out of the
contenders and then the listeners will
vote like I've said this before I love a
full center here oh is that is it kind
of full it's real greasy man no it's so
thick dude I go put some product in
there really putting that in there do
you like I'm not going on a mullet so we
look like beavis and butt-head we look
like live-action beavis and butt-head I
can't do a mullet bro I wouldn't steal
your STIs like that I Bobbi libro oh
yeah
I really did like check out my hair what
dude now is that a typical Korean thing
to do from Bobby Lee for him to sneak in
and steal someone's stall as a very
Korean I
to say past though he did so fast if he
just slowly did it it'd be one thing but
he did so fast that's not Korean you do
it slowly
okay Koreans do it slowly yeah cuz you
guys you guys took it over pop music
like kpop I don't know where to slowly
okay pop is music dude it's a pretty
amazing tree and pop kpop I haven't
heard it I gotta check it out dude is it
good
kpop yeah it's super catchy you love it
who's the biggest one what's her name
BTS right now BTS oh they're boys Ohan
did they send in a submission for King
this thing and they're Jews or not
they're all Korean it's tough to tell if
it's men or women the kpop they wear
makeup
they're like good-looking people but you
can't it's tough I'm gonna watch them
yeah well BTS is fire dude they are oh
their track with Halsey getting in there
like this BTS dude and their beautiful
young fellows huh oh yeah well it's hard
to tell dude oh we are beautiful yeah
that's why I'm saying good-looking human
beings mm-hmm a handsome boys and look
at that on the left is that one on the
left he doesn't look very Korean now
here's the problem k-pop they make these
boys practise 23 hours a day out of the
24 days you know and it's just they just
you can tell they hate their lives
oh yeah yeah it's like Jackson yeah it's
like Michael Jackson's dad your manager
what's all of them so they're all dying
inside and no one of them are rich
because my crisis dad took on money it's
Michael Jackson's dad's band yeah Wow
your enscape oh well I think good lot so
yeah good luck guys send in your
submission I'm a big fan we'll see how
it goes okay pop yeah yes in general if
you guys want to do have a kpop band
send us a submission now freakin also if
there's actual kpop bands out there
amateur kpop bands for sure you tell me
you don't know any Chen
not personally they don't lie to us like
you lied to [ __ ] hot car yeah you did
let's bring that up right now we're
going to talk about let's bring up I
don't want to do it but I've just hit me
bang
no buzz buzz like just so you guys know
and then the fans know - I literally we
me and my girl dated literally after
Carl was picked but it sounds like there
was something that happened on the
episode and let's bring up there was a
comment that somebody saw this image
online of May where you say an
observation observation you don't do
chinnough chinnough nen with where you
said that you were willing to go on
another date with Carl and then at the
end you tell us that you have a
girlfriend
so which one once I'm at her tits yeah
be down for another day o dungeon that
Muppet what your wings yeah how about
that lo mein yeah boy our bear trying to
vein up in that lo mein boy yeah try to
get that egg roll in them noodles you
know mainardi a little Star Wars I
didn't mean to call you want aren't you
yes and I was neither but I thought we
would spin out foods either way edit
that hey no but you sound like you were
in until we found out that she thought
the age was a issue and then kind of
changed your tongue no I was still all
in and I was gonna say that was gonna go
on a second date for I don't want anyone
I don't want to let anyone down so I
wanted to keep it up you let us all down
so what you have a family with her no
family at night and have little mix kids
and let them down every night no we
wouldn't yeah we're gonna put a sword in
your heart in your father's yard game
God we would have ended it there cuz
we're not gonna go on a second date
videotape right so we would end it there
and then I would've told you guys later
I would've told her too but you guys
kept saying we got to find another girl
for chin or something all that stuff was
like no we gotta end it right now I have
to tell you guys right now who's a
company man is that what you're saying
your company my literally went through
all of it for you guys in the fans and I
literally started dating my girl after
the karlie thing after she was picked
I'm sure she'll selected Oh either let
you guys down not going the date or just
do it and have fun but on the date it
sounded like you were trying to go after
them juggles yeah
a little over the top when you say yeah
a little over the top so we act you're
trying you're trying to get some
teriyaki on them kids first am i right
yeah right never but uh let's see here I
just want to know the truth Chen
hey what what's your girl think about
all this chin she wasn't super stoked
about it but she understood yeah sure
she knows sense of humor no she's not
green oh she's not know what is she
Vietnamese wow I love like to say again
this is not me it's not Kat it's not me
I promise no I've met I met the girl I
don't remember I'm CT by metric er this
cat's a single many times he didn't know
that Derek was with you in whatever city
you guys were no I do you in San Jose do
you happen let me up so have you forgot
but yeah yeah you forgot again
welcome to below the belt
you know what's easy is I'm like Daddy
from Fern Gully bro marry him Wow
yeah and he killed himself after that
role no not the bat dude not the bass I
thought was him issues sorry he had some
bats in this belfry man r.i.p Robin
Williams so your girl wasn't too happy
Jen I'd like to make a video with her
and see what her thoughts are we do we
face tyrant if she would like to send in
a video and let her know us a little
know her honest thoughts because I feel
a little bit deceived and I'm not even
know I had to go through with it right
but did it seem you were live with him
cat did it seem like he was willing to
escalate the date to sensual levels if
the honest cat be honest no hold on let
me out let me ask you that did you know
he had a girlfriend cat did he mention
it at all to you before yes I did know
welcome to salt it was a cold case that
kind of [ __ ] sheep cat wouldn't like I
thought maybe so cat D so he's on the up
and up here that was in on the like I'm
hurt guys it was after we picked Carly
alright so either I don't do it or just
do it pretend and half I did have fun
though
well glad some
would you have let it escalate to
sensual activities I couldn't that's why
I said why couldn't you even with the
school for two days it's got the big jug
a month or so right bro she had those
Milka lanterns bro no freaking lats on
the hillside
you're out of your mind bro [ __ ] daddy
just fine Carly's gonna be just fine
okay are you guys still communicating or
not
no you Texan I just texted her and there
we go for what huh huh it's all whoa
dude that night just to make sure she
got home safe well we need to find
someone Derick break up with your girl
hey Kat single I don't catch the one it
gets creepy when we send cannon some
dark web date I don't want that least
Jing can defend himself
yeah that's true kind of he can always
pull that earring off of his ear and pop
somebody's it with it all right let's
get through this half the sub and I'm
starting to get bored these guys got a
pic who'd like between a day and Tyler
its pearly white day we're Tyler with
the wolf rag they're both fantastic and
I appreciate the effort both no losers
there's no I think a good tie bracket
tiebreaker is the original beat our
second guy vicious he made that as South
Vietnam and I thought I missed a beat
though was it that's a rape alarm again
I'm assembling because the first one boy
used the hot boys he's the hot boys
because juvenile B yeah fine which is a
fire now just listen to me today
really that's a shame he takes a little
long to get into it and also his
magician racking best
it's flows not as good either I like it
so Nick's hatin no Nick them like oh
this might have loved the lyrics what
don't you like about him this he's not
the other guy do your work up gang I do
the damn thing hanging this thing I'm
reppin big brown a rat King steel bomb
put it on put the moonlit dawn every
single city he'd be looking for a single
mom yeah that's a trip and I'm a drip
like Derek raw doggin with his chair I'm
a rat chin and promote or Nick cat quit
hating get your feet up for the pic had
to make it really quick buddy tell me
what you think stay with em continue mom
[ __ ] play all right Peter Billy come
forth oh quit touching me but keep
touching me bro yo yo he did that during
his hard give me the other one yeah
we're talking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
number two I'm wrong with your boy
vicious right there beautiful
submissions oh thank you shot the white
rap bang [ __ ] keep fighting the good
fight yeah see you guys in the future
broccolini